اكيد كل يوم لازم يكون في اخبار عن ايلون
ماسك فمن اوائل الاشياء اللي عملها ماسك
لمستحوذ على تويتر كان انه غير اسمه في
البايو تبع حسابه وسمى نفسه رئيس تويتر
وكمان لو تتذكروا وهو حل مجلس الاداره
واعلن نفسه الرئيس التنفيذي للشركه ومن
الاخر يعني هو الكل في الكل ووقتها لما
سال في الموضوع وتم انتقاده قال يا جماعه
الموضوع مؤقت واليوم رجع تاكد هذا الكلام
فخلال جلسه استماع بخصوص بخصوص عفوا
المحاكمه لها علاقه بشركه ثانيه تسلا لهم
ماسك فجر تصريح مفاجاه وقال انه يا جماعه
انا مش نفسي اكون رئيس تنفيذي لاي شركه
اصلا وبخصوص تويتر تحديدا قال انه بدور
على شخص اخر يمسك زمام الامور اول بسمه
الامور تستقر
لهم ماسك للعلم هو حاليا الرئيس التنفيذي
لثلاثه
وظيفه رئاسه تويتر اكيد يعني وظيفه بحلم
فيها كثار من الناس يعني لو فتح ماسك
الباب راح يقدم عليها المئات اذا ما لو ما
كانش الاف حتى مجرد العمل بشركه مثل تويتر
هي حلم لك كثير من الناس لكن في ايميل
داخليه ماسك لموظفين تويتر
وتسرب للاعلام يمكن يغير وجهه النظر هاي
لهم ماسك اللي همم طبعا الردي صار طارد
الاف الموظفين من تويتر بعد ايميل
الموظفين الحاليين بقول لهم في انه الفتره
الجاي الشغل راح يكون كثير صعب وراح يكون
كثير في شغل وامامهم حلين يا اما العمل
المضاعف او الطرد ماسك في رسالته لموظفين
تويتر حط لينك موظفين واعطاهم مهله لحد
يوم الخميس يعني اليوم يعني لحتى ياخذوا
قرارهم وقال لهم الفتره الجايه الفتره
صعبه بدنا نبني فيها تويتر اقوى واجدد
وهذا راح نطلع عمل مكثف ومضاعف وساعات
طويله فاللي مستعد لهذا الشيء يضغط على
هاي اللينك واللي مش مستعد فالله معه وراح
ياخذ تعويض راتب ثلاثه شهور
[موسيقى]